-You know,
you were here in 2015
right after you announced,
and when you announced
that time,
it was not as big of a deal
as it was this time.
You were -- "New York Times"
put it on A21.
-A19.
-A19. Oh, yeah.
-But who's counting?
[ Laughter ]
-A lot has changed.
One thing that's changed
is the party has moved
more to the left,
and also you --
it is a more crowded field.
It seems like a lot of people
are jumping in here.
Do you, having gone through what
you went through four years ago,
feel more prepared?
-I do.
And I think
what I'm excited about
is that many of the ideas
that we talked about
three or four years ago,
which at that time were
thought to be crazy
and extreme and radical,
are now supported
by a considerable majority
of the American people.
So, four years ago,
when we talked about
raising the minimum wage
to a living wage,
15 bucks an hour --
"Oh, my God. You can't do that."
Five states have already
done it in the last year.
That's progress.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, we talked about
ending the disgrace
of the United States being
the only major country on Earth
not to guarantee healthcare
to all people
through a Medicare for All
single payer program.
Crazy idea four years ago,
majority of the American people
support it today,
and that's important.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because healthcare --
Seth, to my mind,
healthcare is a human right,
and it should not matter
whether you're rich,
whether you're poor,
to make certain
that your kid gets
the best possible
healthcare available.
That's what we gotta do.
Public colleges
and universities, tuition free.
It's now an idea
that is spreading
all over this country.
And importantly,
four years ago, I said
we have got to stand up to
the fossil fuel industry.
We have got to transform
our energy system
away from fossil fuel
to energy efficiency
and sustainable energy.
And I think more and more
people understand
that climate change
is an existential threat
to this planet, and we have got
to be aggressive
in transforming
our energy system.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to ask this.
A lot of those issues
obviously distinguished you
from the competition last time.
One of the successes is
you now have convinced
a lot of the people that
are running against you...
-Yeah.
-Do you ever want to say --
'Cause a lot of them obviously
are friends or colleagues.
Do you ever want to say,
"Hey, this is kind of my --
Medicare for All,
that's kind of mine"?
-[ Laughs ]
-Or are you happy that it is
now an consensus?
-I am. Look.
Nobody, you know --
nobody -- no one person
can do it alone.
So, we need a lot of voices
out there.
One of the things also --
you asked me the difference
between now and then.
In the first week
of our campaign, Seth,
we have signed up
1 million volunteers
who are prepared
to roll up their sleeves
and get to work not only to
help me win the nomination
and to defeat
the most dangerous president
in modern history, Mr. Trump...
[ Applause ]
...but also to help us
take on
the very powerful
special interests --
Wall Street,
the fossil fuel industry,
and the military
industrial complex --
that have just so much power
over the economic and political
life of this country.
-So many senators running.
Obviously, you see them.
They are your colleagues.
Is it awkward
that you all know
that you're all trying
to be president?
-[ Laughs ]
You know, look...
[ Laughter ]
-I'll take that as a yes.
-The short answer is yes.
-Yeah, okay, I got it.
That's human. I would say
that's a human reaction.
-Yeah, we all have lunch
together every Tuesday,
and you got half the caucus
running for -- for president.
You know what I'm saying?
It is kind of strange,
but on the other hand, you know,
we have known each other --
I've known Elizabeth Warren
for like 20 years.
I've known many of the other
senators for a long time,
and we're friends.
And I think what all of us
understand --
obviously each and every one of
us wants to win the nomination.
I certainly do.
But I think we all understand
that no matter who wins,
everybody is going to rally
around that candidate
and defeat Donald Trump.
That is most important.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's nice to hear.